socke hengst vom pc und
videospiel starcraft also
ich hab noch nie gespielt also wie kann
wie kommt es dazu gekommen dass du halt
starcraft spiels was reizt dich an
starcraft
also ist da klafft ein spiel ich seit
ich mit
890 angefangen ich habe euch dann elf
ein auto das 2004 gespielt auch auf dem
niveau also waren das schon mal fünf
jahre und zwei jetzt die seit eineinhalb
jahren ungefähr also sechseinhalb jahren
spiele ich
warum ich so gut bin ja ich habe mal war
der ziemlich viel gespielt spiel immer
noch relativ viel und zurzeit
viel spiel so spielen manche tage gar
nicht andere dann 56 stunden vielleicht
je nachdem